c'est là bonjour alors quel est le mot
d'ordre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
eh bien écoutez amira ont protesté
contre les vagues de licenciements et
défendre l'emploi se ce sont les mots
d'ordre de cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui une mobilisation à
l'initiative de plusieurs organisations
syndicales à qu'ils soient du secteur de
l'hôtellerie du tourisme ou encore des
services tous entendent ici à je cite m
en francs au cortège des annonces de
suppressions massives d'emplois ils
estiment sains pour certains que la
crise sanitaire a servent de prétexte au
capitalisme et au patronat pour
licencier se sont alors mots et puis
dans ce cortège nous avons rencontré à
stéphane stéphane il est élu à la cgt
depuis le voyagiste je vous propose
d'écouter son témoignage nous on est
numéro un mondial du touriste et le
voyages nouvelles frontières marmara et
donc on a subi un plan social annoncé en
visioconférence par notre pdg
confortablement installé au maroc en
juin
donc on a commencé à se battre contre ce
plan social de notre côté et on a des
salariés qui sont venus nous soutenir
il ya eu au monoprix il ya eu karim
d'edf qui sont venus le soutien donc
nous on leur a rendu la monnaie de leur
pièce et on a été les soutiens également
et petit à petit on a pris goût à cette
lutte et on s'est rendu compte y en
avait beaucoup d'invisibles de boîtes
partout en province qui licenciait qu'on
ne l'entendait pas du tout parlé dans
les médias
donc on s'est dit il faut sortir du
combat boîte par boîte et mutualiser les
luttes parce que 2020 ça a été une année
où on a été bâillonnée il faut que 2021
on soit visible et qu'on soit tous dans
la rue
voilà amira pour les revendications le
cortège j'aurais tant voulu 10 et est en
train de prendre la direction du siège
du medef et puis sachez que on a croisé
quelques élus de la france subit c'est
le cas par exemple de jean luc mélenchon
d'adrien qu'un plan soit mort de
manoeuvre ou pas merci et celle pour ses
précédents on vous retrouve certainement
lors de nos prochaines éditions et vous
par